Este video es patrocinado por
Manscaped.com, luego os doy
más detalles pero antes, vamos
con nuestra historia de hoy.
Irlanda es uno de los países más ricos del mundo.
Pero eso ya lo sabéis. Prácticamente todas las
grandes tecnológicas, desde Apple hasta Google,
tienen su sede Europea en Irlanda. Si trabajas en
algo relacionado con IT seguro que alguna vez te
ha llegado alguna oferta para trabajar en Dublín.
Lo que probablemente no sepáis es que es REALMENTE
rico. Más rico, incluso, que Suiza ¡Pero no sólo
eso! Irlanda lleva más de una década creciendo
a ritmos de país emergente ¿Os acordáis del
año 2020? Sí, el año del Coronavirus. Ese año
en el que prácticamente todos los países del
mundo entraron en recesión. Pues bien, Irlanda
no sólo siguió creciendo: es que su PIB creció
al 5.8%. Para que os hagáis una idea, estas son
cifras propias de un país como China o Vietnam.
Todo esto es sorprendente, sobre todo, si tenemos
en cuenta que muchos economistas llevan años
prediciendo un supuesto colapso económico en
Irlanda. Entre ellos está el Premio Nóbel de
Economía, Paul Krugman. Sin embargo, en estos
momentos, el salario medio en Irlanda está en
44.200 dólares anuales. Y, en el año 2015,
Irlanda rompió todos los records imaginables
cuando crecieron al 25%. Sí, habéis oído bien: 25%
de crecimiento del PIB (Vale, este número tiene
trampa, pero hablaremos de esto más adelante). La
pregunta es ¿Por qué? ¿Qué hace que Irlanda sea
tan increíblemente próspera? Seguramente muchos
ya tengáis una respuesta en la cabeza: Impuestos
bajos ¡Exacto! Irlanda tiene uno de los impuestos
de sociedades más bajos del mundo. Esto ha servido
para atraer a las mayores multinacionales del
mundo. Sin embargo, atentos a esta noticia.
La República de Irlanda subirá
su impuesto de sociedades al 15%
Y al pregunta es: ahora que van a subir el
impuesto de sociedades ¿Se acabó la gallina
de los huevos de oro? ¿O tal vez Irlanda es
mucho más que un país con impuestos bajos?
¿Por qué Irlanda es tan rico? ¿Por qué siguen
creciendo como si fueran un país emergente? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
SHIPPING UP TO BOSTON
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos,
especialmente los que veáis este vídeo desde
Estados Unidos. Lo primero que os viene a la
cabeza cuando pensáis en Irlanda es… ¡El desfile
de San Patricio en… Boston! Ese desfile que ya se
ha hecho famoso por el tradicional concierto de
los Dropkick Murphy´s. Y sí, habéis oído bien,
he dicho Boston, Massachussets, y no Dublín.
Lo cierto es que hay más descendientes de
Irlandeses viviendo en Estados Unidos que en
la propia Irlanda. Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver como Irlanda ha estado
perdiendo población desde el siglo 19. Es decir,
desde antes incluso de independizarse de Reino
Unido. Y esto tiene una explicación: pobreza.
Durante siglos, la isla de Irlanda era parte
del Reino Unido… pero eran pobres de solemnidad.
Los irlandeses eran ciudadanos de segunda. Y no
creáis que hablamos de pobreza dentro del primer
mundo. Hablamos de auténtica miseria. Para que os
hagáis una idea, sólo en los años 40 del siglo 19,
más de 1 millón de irlandeses murieron de hambre.
Sin embargo… en el año 1937 y, tras una cruenta
guerra civil, la República de Irlanda redactó
su Constitución. Sin embargo, la pobreza y el
hambre persistieron ¿Por qué? La respuesta
está en la política. Tras independizarse,
Irlanda apostó por un modelo económico basado en
la autosuficiencia. Pensadlo bien: Estados Unidos
todavía estaba recuperándose del Crack del 29.
El libre mercado no estaba precisamente de moda.
Así que Irlanda quería conseguir la independencia
económica: no querían importar nada del exterior
¿Conclusión? Ya os la podéis imaginar. El
proteccionismo rara vez funciona. Pero, si
hay un país donde es aún más difícil que funcione,
ese era Irlanda. Hablamos de una isla con menos
de 4 millones de habitantes que a duras penas
estaba industrializada. Como os podéis imaginar,
es difícil que una economía tan pequeña pueda
llegar a ser autosuficiente. Así que, ante la
falta de importaciones, Irlanda siguió liderando
las exportaciones de una cosa: Irlandeses. Eso
explica que algunas ciudades americanas como
Boston tengan una conexión tan fuerte con Irlanda.
Sin embargo, las cosas empezaron a cambiar en
el año 1959 con este señor que veis en pantalla:
SEAN THOMAS O´KELLY. Este señor era el primer
ministro de Irlanda y es el padre del primer
INTENTO de liberalizar la economía irlandesa. Y
diréis ¿Por qué digo “intento de”? Pues porque
el bueno de O´Kelly sólo aplicó algunas partes de
la receta. En el año 1959, creó una zona de libre
comercio al lado del Aeropuerto de Shannon.
Así es como llegaron las primeras empresas
extranjeras. Durante las décadas posteriores,
Irlanda redujo los impuestos a empresas para
atraer a aún más empresas. Por ejemplo, Apple
se estableció en Irlanda en 1980. Sin embargo,
nada de esto sirvió para que los irlandeses
vivieran mejor. Más bien todo lo contrario. Por
un lado, las empresas extranjeras se limitaban a
establecer sus sedes fiscales. Nada más. Es decir,
que las primeras oficinas de Apple o Hewlett
Packard tenían sólo unos pocos contables en
plantilla ¡Pero no sólo eso! Por aquellos
años, Irlanda apenas tenía industria. Sus
empresas estaban ancladas en el siglo 19. Así
que, al permitir las importaciones, los productos
extranjeros reventaban el mercado ¿Conclusión?
En 1987, Irlanda tenía un paro del 17%. Los
sueldos eran una tercera parte de su
equivalente en Reino Unido. Y Irlanda
volvía a liderar una exportación: Irlandeses.
Dicho de otra forma: por mucho que Irlanda
bajara su impuesto de sociedades, Irlanda seguía
siendo un país pobre. Y la pregunta es ¿Entonces…
cómo ha llegado Irlanda a ser el Tigre Celta
que conocemos hoy en día? Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver.
EL
RUGIDO DEL TIGRE CELTA
La pregunta, la gran pregunta
de la Irlanda de los años 80 era… ¿Qué
hace falta para que las multinacionales
contraten a irlandeses? Vale, OK, os estamos
poniendo la alfombra roja para que montéis
oficinas en nuestro país ¡Pero queremos oficinas
de verdad! ¡No sólo una sede fiscal! Pues bien,
esa es la pregunta que se hizo el señor CHARLES
HAGNEY, que era el Primer Ministro de Irlanda
en 1987. Este buen señor y su equipo se dieron
cuenta de una cosa: sí, es cierto, Irlanda tenía
impuestos bajos para empresas… ¡Pero todo lo demás
era un auténtico caos! Los trabajadores tenían que
pagar hasta un 60% de Impuesto de la Renta. Y la
legislación laboral era tan estricta que contratar
y despedir se convertía en un auténtico
via crucis burocrático ¿Conclusión? Hagney
hizo la auténtica liberalización que necesitaba
Irlanda. Y los resultados no se hicieron esperar.
“La planta de Hewlett Packard en Leixlip
dará 2000 trabajos para el año 2000”
De repente, los medios irlandeses empezaron
a publicar noticias como esta casi todos los
meses. Para que os hagáis una idea, en
poco más de una década, los irlandeses
pasaron de cobrar dos terceras partes de lo que
cobraban de sus vecinos ingleses a superarlos.
Eran los años del tigre celta. El país estaba
on fire ¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de multinacionales! Por estos años,
surgieron un montón de gigantes irlandeses:
¿OS suena Primark? ¿Os suena Ryanair? Pues
todo esto son empresas que nacieron o que
empezaron a expandirse por estos
años. Para que os hagáis una idea,
hablamos de una época tan próspera, que
incluso se llegó a poner de moda celebrar
bodas y bautizos… ¡Desde un helicóptero! Los
Bancos daban hipotecas a diestro y siniestro.
Y los Irlandeses se acostumbraron pronto a
vivir bien. Muy bien. Dicho de otra forma:
Irlanda era algo así como el sueño húmedo de
cualquier liberal. La prueba de que el libre
mercado funciona de forma casi milagrosa. Sin
embargo… la alegría duró sólo unos años. Atentos.
EFECTO DOMINÓ
Podríamos decir que Irlanda es el puente que
une Estados Unidos con Europa. Eso significa que
los bancos irlandeses estaban demasiado expuestos
a los bancos estadounidenses. Eso explica que
la gran crisis financiera del año 2008 golpeara
especialmente a Irlanda. Atentos a esta gráfica.
Crecimiento de PIB de Irlanda
vs Estados Unidos (2003-2013)
Aquí podéis ver cómo Irlanda
sufrió una recesión incluso peor que Estados
Unidos. Y ya os podéis imaginar la cantidad de
economistas y analistas que entonaban el “¡¡¡Te
lo dije!!!” por aquellos años ¡Pero eso no es
todo! ¿Qué creéis que hizo Irlanda para evitar el
colapso de sus bancos? ¡Exacto! Pedir un rescate.
Tanto la Unión Europea como el Fondo
Monetario Internacional rescataron a
Irlanda con un préstamo de 67.500 millones
de euros. Para que os hagáis una idea,
esto es un 40% de todo el PIB del país ¿Y
cómo quería devolver Irlanda todo este dinero?
¡Exacto! Con medidas de austeridad. Dicho de otra
forma, Irlanda subió algunos impuestos indirectos
y recortó el gasto público en todos los frentes.
Bajaron los sueldos a los funcionarios en un 14%,
cerraron hasta 41 agencias del Gobierno.
Como os podéis imaginar, todo esto desató
las mayores protestas de la Irlanda moderna. Y
ahí es cuando los economistas como Paul Krugman
volvieron a entonar el ¡¡¡TE LO DIJE!!! Atentos.
Irlanda está ahora en su tercer año de austeridad
y la confianza sigue cayendo. Deberíais
preguntaros qué hace falta para que la
gente serie se de cuenta de que castigar a
la población por los pecados de sus banqueros
es peor que un crimen: es un error.
–Paul Krugman en The New York Times
Quedaos con esta cita: es de un artículo
escrito en el año 2010. Pues bien,
dos años más tarde, el tiempo decidió
contradecir a Paul Krugman. Atentos.
Como podéis ver, Irlanda no sólo se ha
recuperado de la crisis. Es que ahora mismo
es sustancialmente más rico que el propio Estados
Unidos. Y sí, fijaos bien en el salto que da entre
2014 y 2016. Esa es la fecha en la que Irlanda
batió todos los records y llegó a crecer hasta un
25% de su PIB. La pregunta es ¿Cómo lo hicieron?
¿Hay algo de trampa? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CUANDO EL PIB NO ES SUFICIENTE
Imaginaos la cara de Paul Krugman. Predijo el
colapso económico de Irlanda, un “austericidio”…
que nunca llegó. En pocos años, Irlanda dejó de
lado la crisis de deuda y volvió a crecer como
si no hubiera mañana ¡No sólo a crecer! Es que
incluso llegó a batir todos los records de la
historia económica: una tasa de crecimiento del
25% ¡Boom! ¡Así Sorry not sorry, China! Así que
¿Qué creéis que hizo el bueno de Krugman? Pues
ponerse a investigar la auténtica razón de
ese crecimiento tan espectacular. Atentos.
La economía del Leprechaun: ¡Irlanda reporta
un 26% de crecimiento! Esto no tiene sentido
¿Por qué está esto en el PIB? –Paul Krugman
Y lo cierto es que, en este caso, Krugman tenía
toda la razón del mundo. Esa subida de más del 25%
del PIB se debe a que las grandes multinacionales
(Principalmente Apple) movieron sus beneficios a
Irlanda para beneficiarse de esos impuestos tan
bajos. Para que os hagáis una idea, sólo Apple
llegó a mover más de 147.000 millones de euros a
Irlanda entre 2004 y 2014. Se trata de una simple
operación financiera. Pero 147.000 millones de
euros es una auténtica salvajada de dinero… sobre
todo para un país pequeño como Irlanda, con un PIB
que ahora, en 2022, está en los 418.000 millones
de euros. Dicho de otra forma: la estadística no
refleja la realidad. Todo ese dinero de Apple no
ha llegado a la economía irlandesa. En realidad,
es sólo un número en un balance. Y lo
cierto es que Apple no son los únicos.
Según el FMI, el 60% de la inversión extranjera
en Irlanda son simples números. A esto,
Krugman lo llamó “leprechaun economics” (Los
leprechaun son unos duendes de la mitología
irlandesa). Dicho de otra forma… la econometría
clásica, simplemente no funciona en Irlanda.
Las distorsiones estadísticas creadas por
el impacto de los activos globales y las
actividades de las multinacionales
en las cuentas nacionales irlandesas
se han vuelto tan grandes que el
PIB de Irlanda es ahora una broma.
--Patrick Honohan, ex gobernador
del Banco Central de Irlanda
De hecho, a día de hoy, Irlanda utiliza unas
magnitudes distintas que el resto de países para
medir su economía ¿Cuáles son esas magnitudes?
¿Cómo se mide el PIB? Este tipo de preguntas
no son propias de VisualPolitik pero sí tienen
cabida en… ¡VisualEconomik! Por si no lo sabéis,
tenemos un canal hermano donde hablamos en
profundidad de nuestra otra gran pasión:
la economía. Si os interesan este tipo
de cuestiones, os esperamos por ahí.
Pero volvamos con nuestra historia de hoy.
Distorsiones estadísticas a parte, el fenómeno
de las Leprechaun Economics sirvió para poner en
el debate todos los esquemas fiscales de Irlanda.
Montones de multinacionales han estado
aprovechando los impuestos bajos de Irlanda
para crear esquemas fiscales con los que pagar
muy pocos impuestos. De hecho, para el año 2017,
tanto la Unión Europea como Estados Unidos han
sacado varias medidas para evitar la competencia
fiscal de Irlanda ¡Y no sólo eso! El propio
gobierno de Irlanda ya se ha comprometido a
subir los impuestos. Atentos.
La República de Irlanda subirá
su impuesto de sociedades al 15%
Y la pregunta es… ¿Hasta qué punto Paul
Krugman tiene razón? Es decir, si la riqueza de
Irlanda se debe a trampas contables y tributación
baja… ¿Estamos ante el fin del milagro
irlandés? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
MADE IN IRELAND
Vamos a decirlo claro: el éxito de Irlanda
no consiste en atraer a grandes empresas con
impuestos bajos. Si la prosperidad fuera tan
simple como bajar impuestos, Andorra sería un
país de millonarios y Liberia no sería tan pobre.
El auténtico éxito de Irlanda consiste en haber
logrado que esas empresas se establezcan
de verdad en el país y contraten gente ¡No
sólo eso! Irlanda ha conseguido que surjan en el
propio país empresas propias que ya son gigantes.
Por ejemplo ¿Os suena Ryanair? Se trata del
gigante de los vuelos low cost. Si vivís en
Europa, seguro que algún día habréis volado con
esta empresa. Se trata de una de las empresas
más disruptivas de la historia. Pero lo
cierto es que Ryanair sólo es la punta
del iceberg de una industria muchísimo más
grande. Puede que os sorprenda pero Irlanda
es la potencia mundial en aerolíneas ¡Tal
cual como lo oís! Quedaos con estos nombres:
AERCAP, GE CAPITAL AVIATION SERVICES o
AVOLON… seguramente nunca hayáis oído
hablar de estas empresas. Pero son
los titanes del alquiler de aviones.
La mayor parte de las aerolíneas comerciales del
mundo no tienen sus propios aviones: los alquilan.
Pues bien, el 22% de los aviones comerciales que
vuelan por el mundo vienen de empresas irlandesas.
Hablamos de una industria que ha llegado a dar
más de 4000 puestos de trabajo ¿Y qué me decís
del software? Cierto, este es el sector donde
están todas esas grandes multinacionales. Desde
Google hasta Facebook, todas ellas tienen su sede
fiscal en Irlanda… ¡Pero no sólo hablamos de sedes
fiscales! Sólo el sector software da trabajo
a 24.000 personas. No está nada mal si tenemos
en cuenta que la población de irlanda no llega a
los 5 millones de habitantes. En otras palabras:
la economía de Irlanda no sólo está hiper
diversificada, además está llena de líderes
mundiales. Y todo esto explica que ni siquiera
el coronavirus haya hecho mella en el país.
Dicho de otra forma, no parece que Irlanda esté
al borde de ninguna crisis importante. Al menos,
no el tipo de crisis que se imaginaría Paul
Krugman ¿Significa esto que los Irlandeses
no tienen problemas? No exactamente. Pero
hablamos de otro tipo de crisis. Atentos.
La crisis de la vivienda decidirá
el futuro político de Irlanda
¡Exacto! Esto es la cara B del éxito económico.
Irlanda ya no exporta mano de obra ¡Todo lo
contrario! Ciudades como Dublin o Cork están
recibiendo gente de todas partes. Y apenas
hay casas para hospedar a tanta gente. No
hablamos de un problema menor. Y además,
se trata de algo que afecta a muchos
otros países… pero Irlanda tiene un
problema especialmente acuciante en este sentido.
La pregunta ahora es ¿Cómo se puede solucionar? Y
lo que es más importante ¿Qué lecciones se pueden
sacar del modelo irlandés para otros países?
¿Cómo creéis que le afectará a Irlanda la crisis
provocada por la Guerra de Ucrania? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios. Recordad
visitar nuestro nuevo canal, VisualEconomik,
donde hablamos en profundidad de nuestra otra
gran pasión: la economía. Y no olvidéis que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas, así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.